hi everyone this is Professor M the
science and today I want to discuss
hermitian operators this is another one
of our videos on rigorous quantum
mechanics hermitian operators are the
most important type of operator in
quantum mechanics because they allow us
to describe physical observables today
we will learn two things first that the
eigenvalues of hermitian operators are
real numbers this is important because
physical quantities are typically
described by real numbers second that
the eigen state of a hermitian operator
from a basis in state space this is
important because in order to predict
the outcome of a measurement in quantum
mechanics we first need to represent the
state we're measuring in the basis of
the eigenstates of the operator let's go
a hermitian operator a is an operator
that is equal to its adjoint remember
from the video on operators that even
operator a acts on a ket side to give
another cat's-eye Prime then in the dual
space the adjoint operator a dagger is
the operator that acts on the bra side
and gives the props i prime an immediate
implication of a being hermitian is that
we can rewrite this last expression as
the operator a acting on the perhaps I
and then giving the props I prime what I
want to do in the rest of the video is
to study two important features of
hermitian operators the first is that
the eigenvalues of a hermitian operator
are real numbers this is in fact
reassuring because hermitian operators
are the operators representing physical
observables in quantum mechanics and
physical observables tend to be
characterized by real numbers the second
property is that the eigenstate of a
hermitian operator can be chosen to form
an orthonormal set and that they set
forms a basis in state space what this
means is that we can always write an
arbitrary quantum state in the
representation given by the eigenstate
of a physical observable and we will see
that this property becomes key when
discussing measurements in quantum
mechanics let's start with eigen values
the eigen value equation is a sy equals
lambda beside where the lambda is the
eigen value and beside the eigen state
what we do first is to
act from the right on both sides of this
equation with the bra side to obtain
this the next thing I want to do is to
rewrite the eigenvalue equation in the
drill space remember that an operator
becomes the adjoint operator a dagger
and the scaler becomes the complex
conjugate lambda star this is a general
expression for any operator a if we now
insist that our operator is a hermitian
operator then we can replace a dagger by
a the final step is to act with the cat
side from the right and we get this the
left-hand sides of these two equations
here and here are the same so the
right-hand sides must also be the same
acquainting them leads to this equation
here remember that the scalar product of
a cat with itself is a positive number
and it is only zero for the trivial case
of the null vector a equals zero this
means that in general this bracket will
not be zero so that lambda star must
equal lambda for this equation to hold
this in turn implies that lambda is a
real number
therefore the eigenvalues of a hermitian
operator are real numbers let's now move
to item States we consider the first
eigenstate sy with eigenvalue lambda and
the second eigen state Phi with
eigenvalue mu the first scenario we look
at is when lambda mu are different
eigenvalues the first step is to operate
with the broth I on the first equation
to get this for the second equation we
start by transforming into the dual
space and remember that a is hermitian
so we don't need the dagger and mu is
real as we just proved so we don't need
the complex conjugate either then we
operate with the cat's-eye to get this
the left-hand side of these two
equations are the same so we can equate
the right-hand sides to obtain this
because for now we're working with
lambda different from you then this can
only be true if the bracket between Phi
and psi is 0
therefore the eigenstate of a hermitian
operator corresponding to different
eigenvalues are orthogonal what this
means is that if all our eigenvalues are
different then all eigenstates are
mutually orthogonal so we can normalize
them and form an orthonormal basis of
our state space what we will see in the
rest of the video is that this is true
even if lambda and mu are the same but
in this case the situation is a little
more subtle because we can no longer
conclude that Phi and PSI are orthogonal
so what we want to do next is to see
what happens to again States when we
have the generate eigenvalues first
let's remember some of the properties of
the generate eigenvalues the eigen value
equation for an n-fold degenerate eigen
value becomes a PSI I equals lambda psi
I where I runs from 1 to n and labels
the n eigen states that share the same
eigen value lambda we showed in the
video on eigen values that you can make
any linear combination of these eigen
States to form a new Cadfael and that
this new ket is also an item state of a
with the same eigen value lambda what
this mean is that for an n-fold
degenerate eigen value then any cat that
lives in the n dimensional subspace of
state space spanned by the set of eigen
ket's pi i is also a valid eigen State
this first property is true for any
operator pit hermitian or not the second
important point to remember is that for
an n fault the generate eigenvalue of a
hermitian operator there are n linearly
independent eigen states in turn what
this means is that for an n dimensional
state space there are n linearly
independent eigen states of these eigen
States those belonging to different
eigen values are orthogonal as we proved
in the previous slide but all we can say
about those belonging to the generate
eigen values is that they are linearly
independent but may not be mutually
orthogonal what I want to show next is
how we can make all these states
mutually orthogonal to get an
orthonormal basis for state space we
know that any linear combination of the
eigen state of an n-fold the generate
subspace gives another ket that is also
an eigenstate with the same eigen value
this property means that we can always
build a new set of mutually orthogonal
eigen State in this sub space by making
Lim
combinations of them the process is
pretty straightforward
and is called gram-schmidt
orthonormalization this works in exactly
the same way for any set of linearly
independent vectors in any vector space
so you may already have encountered it
in other areas what I will do here is to
sketch how it works and you can fill in
the gaps yourself I will call the
original set of linearly independent but
not necessarily orthogonal States beside
I and the new set that we want to build
Phi I and what we want is that the Phi I
are mutually orthonormal the first step
is to pick Phi 1 as proportional to psi
1 the proportionality constant is to
make sure that the state is normalized
the second step is to build the state
that is perpendicular to Phi 1 to do
that we define a ket Chi 2 which we set
equal to psi 2 plus some multiple of the
first state Phi 1 what we want is that
Chi 2 is orthogonal to Phi 1 so we
insist that this bracket here is 0
plugging in the expression for Chi 2 we
get this we can now see that this term
will vanish if we choose alpha to be
equal to minus Phi 1 Phi 2 replacing
this expression above we obtain how to
build Chi 2 in terms of sy 2 and Phi 1
while ensuring it is orthogonal to Phi 1
we then define Phi 2 to be parallel to
Chi 2 but choose it to be normalized so
does this recipe make sense
it is easy to understand what we're
doing here by analogy to a two
dimensional Euclidean space let's
imagine we have two linearly independent
vectors that are not necessarily
orthogonal V 1 and V 2 we pick V 1 as a
reference and then we want to make a new
state from V 2 that is orthogonal to V 1
to start V 2 has a component parallel to
V 1 which I draw in green and is given
by v2 dot v1 hat in the v1 direction
where V 1 hat is the unit vector in the
V one direction and then it has a second
component which here I call W 2 this w 2
vector is perpendicular to V 1 so this
is the new vector that I am looking for
therefore all I need to do is to make it
proportional to V 2 and then subtract
the component of V 2
on v1 in this analogy w2 is equivalent
to Chi 2 the original vector v2 is
equivalent to the original cat situ and
the part that we removed parallel to V 2
is equivalent to the part that we remove
here parallel to Phi 1 for n dimensional
subspace all we need to do to construct
the rest of item States to make a
mutually orthonormal set is to repeat
the same procedure the end result is a
new set of eigenstates Phi I which form
an orthonormal basis in the in
dimensional subspace and put in all
subspaces together we get the basis for
the entire state space the last thing I
want to do is to investigate what
hermitian operators look like in the
matrix formulation of quantum mechanics
as you can probably guess they are
written down in terms of hermitian
matrices to see this remember that the
adjoint of an operator is given by the
transpose conjugate matrix in terms of
matrix elements even operator a has
matrix elements a IJ then the matrix
elements of the adjoint operator a
dagger or a ji its star for a hermitian
operator a and a dagger are the same so
a IJ is equal to a ji star so what does
this matrix look like let's start by
writing the matrix representing the
hermitian operator a what we want to
investigate is whether we can say
anything more specific about what the
elements of this matrix look like when
the matrix is hermitian to do that we
first consider the diagonal elements of
the matrix and for these elements we
have that I equals J so that AI I equals
a I I star which in turn implies that AI
is a real number
what about the off diagonal entries in
this case all we can say is that a IJ is
equal to AJ I star for example the a12
element here must be the complex
conjugate of the a21 element here this
means that the matrix of a hermitian
operator a first has diagonal elements
which are real numbers shown in green
here and then there is some relation
between the entries on either side of
the diagonal if this is entry a 1 2 then
this entry here is a 1 to start the same
happens for a 1 3 and this entry here
and
what we just found about how to write
down a hermitian operator in the matrix
formulation of quantum theory is true
irrespective of the state space basis in
which we write the operator however we
have found earlier in the video that the
eigenstate of a hermitian operator can
be chosen themselves to form a basis so
a natural question that arises is
whether there is anything special about
the basis from by the eigenstate of a
given operator the answer to this
question has tremendous importance in
quantum mechanics and features
prominently in what happens when you
measure the physical property associated
with the operator you can learn more
about this by following the link in the
description below but all I want to do
here is to show what the matrix
associated with a looks like when we
write it in the basis of eigenstates of
a let's start by writing the eigenvalue
equation for a and i will pick the
eigenstates phi n to be orthonormal so
what does the operator a look like in
the five bases its matrix elements are
given by this expression we can then use
the eigenvalue equation to determine the
action of a on phi n and plugging this
back in gives this then using the
orthonormality relation here we obtain
lambda M Delta n M what this means is
that the matrix elements vanish unless M
equals M which means that the matrix is
diagonal furthermore the diagonal
entries are simply the eigenvalues of
the operator a so let's write down the
matrix remember that we found that the
matrix associated with a hermitian
operator had real entries in the
diagonal it is clearly true here as the
eigenvalues of a hermitian operator are
real numbers remember also that the off
diagonal elements will complex
conjugates of each other and this is
again true here in a trivial manner as
all these entries are 0 putting this
together the matrix associated with an
operator a is diagonal when written in
the basis spanned by the eigenstates of
the operator and the diagonal entries
are simply the eigenvalues of the
operator before we wrap up let me
emphasize that this result is something
that we will encounter time and again in
quantum mechanics so make sure you're
comfortable with it so
have we learned about hermitian
operators these operators have two
properties which are essential when we
study quantum mechanics the first one is
that there item values are real numbers
and the second that their item states
form a basis in state space both of
these properties become fundamental when
we study measurements in quantum
mechanics if you want to see how this
comes about check out the videos on
measurements if you liked the video or
if like send me suggestions for future
videos please subscribe